Hello! I'm Emmett.
I'm just gonna come right out.
I have no idea what's going on at all.
My fellow master builders, including but not limited to, Superman, Wonder Woman,...
...The Mermaid, Green Ninja, 1980-something space guy...
Hello!
...Michelangelo, Michelangelo, and the 2002 NBA All-Stars.
We have learned that Lord Business plans to end the world as we know it.
There is yet one hope.
The Special has arisen.
I think I got it.
But just in case, tell me the whole thing again, I wasn't listening.
I'm freaking out!
Relax, everybody, I'm here.
Batman? Awesome!
Could you make one of these in orange?
I only work in black.
And sometimes very very dark gray.
Hey, pal, I hate to tell you this, but I don't think you're supposed to be here.
Well, I guess I'm gonna have to report....
No, wait!
Wait up!